the new 20/20 iPad pro is out and it's
definitely something to talk about
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas welcome back to the channel today
we're talking about the brand new 20/20
I pad Pro all its amazing features and
if it truly is the best iPad on the
market we're going to be comparing it to
the iPad Mini and the iPad air so as we
all know the iPad pro was released just
a few short weeks ago the main upgrade
we have seen is the rear camera bomber
like all the new iPhones and all the new
samson's is coming out with more and
more cameras in the back the one thing I
don't really realize is who's using that
camera on the back and I pad personally
that's not my cup of tea but obviously
people are definitely going out and
taking photos with their iPads the new
iPad pro will feature a triple camera
setup on the back which is technically
only a dual camera setup you have a 12
megapixel wide camera and also a 10
megapixel ultra wide camera the third
camera on the back isn't technically a
camera it's a depth sensing camera a
lidar sensor it is used for augmented
reality and that is basically it so I
can see that Apple is going for a very
very big push on augmented reality which
is going to be really cool because you
can do some lots of stuff but right now
in 2020 that augmented reality sensor
that lidar sensor has no real advanced
purpose and considering that the iPad
pro 11 inch model starts at 1379
Australian dollars this is very steep
for what is basically just the old iPad
pro I do continue to focus on this
camera update and the camera module
itself so instead of getting a 43
megapixel panoramic image you get a
sixty three megapixel panoramic again
not really too sure how much value there
is in that but that's okay that's
personally you go up to 4k video with
cinematic stabilization and continuous
autofocus these features are really
really good on a smartphone and on a
camera but on an iPad I'm not too sure
how good they are how many people were
going to be running around with that
iPad you're not got a capture these got
to see that I don't know I guess the
older generation definitely does use
their iPads very differently to how the
younger generation uses it so there is
probably a purpose and a reason for this
and it's definitely a welcomed upgrade I
love seeing good quality video
regardless of the product it comes from
what does pique my interest I think has
peaked in many reviewers interest at the
same time is the new magic keyboard that
basically allows your iPad to float in
air majestically so this magic keyboard
is literally a new phase for the iPad to
take it from just the tablet to truly a
computer and I think it is a good step
in the right direction it does
significantly differentiate an iPad from
any other tablet just sitting there on
the table being a tablet basically so I
think this is a really good product and
I can't wait to review it when it does
actually come out properly and the rest
of the spec bumps are kind of
insignificant as well the a12 chip now
goes to an ATM Z chip which is kind of
like going from an iPhone to iPhone s
it's like awkward in-between stage
they're just trying to get you to buy
the next product so they can make a
little bit more money so from a
performance point of view it hasn't been
able to increase it that much and give
you that much more power and demand and
tablet overall we're not getting the
biggest update and we're not getting the
biggest jumps in performance we are
getting a new iPad pro that looks
exactly the same as the old run it's
still USBC it still does everything the
same it just has a bigger camera on the
back
so from iPad pro one type at pro to not
enough of a jump in my personal opinion
does that mean it is still the king of
all iPads well let's compare them
against the iPad Mini and the iPad air
so to create a fair and reasonable
comparison we'll start with the iPad pro
11 inch the iPad air 10.5 inch and the
iPad Mini 7.19 the iPad pro comes in at
1329 Australian the iPad air 779 and the
iPad Mini 599 the iPad pro is the only
one with the upgraded chip of the eight
holes dead processor both the air and
the mini hug and a 12 chip both the air
and mini again have 256 gigabytes of
maximum storage while still iPad pro
jumps up to one terabyte both the iPad
air it's pretty much similar down the
whole line I'll try pointing out when
they different have one camera versus
the three camera set up on the iPad pro
they both only film in 1080p versus 4k
video imminent video recording mode they
both only have tap to focus versus
continuous autofocus the rear cameras
are identical on the air and the mini at
8 megapixels versus the 12 and 10 on the
iPad pro all three of them actually have
a 7 megapixel front-facing camera so for
any video conferencing app you're going
to be getting the exact same video
quality out of these three devices the
iPad pro does have a little bit of a leg
up with four internal speakers versus
the two in both the other devices
whether the iPad pro again having that
superiority of the magic keyboard
yeah iPad air having
Pat ability with the smart Keyboard and
the I've had many only having privileged
to a Bluetooth connected keyboard both
the arrow Mini only have access to a
first-generation pencil I've had Pro has
second-generation whilst both the air
and mini use lightning cables versus aus
they see what does get interesting here
is the fact that the iPad Mini has a 326
pixels per inch display resolution
versus the 264 pixels per inch in the
iPad air and the iPad pro so from a
pixel density point of view the iPad
Mini actually has one of the highest
density pixel screen ratios versus the
other two all three have a 10 hour
battery life whilst the iPad Mini and
the iPad air have touch ID versus face
ID on the iPad pro so from a very
generic specs point of view and giving
the fact that I have access to all three
of these I use them in my daily life
there's the iPad Mini which my partner
uses absolutely every day I use a
standard iPad air at 99 percent of time
and on occasion I take the iPad pro to
client meetings for what I personally do
I need a bigger screen so I do like the
iPad air I don't think I can justify the
double value for the iPad pro for an
everyday user I think that the iPad Mini
is hands down the best iPad on the
market for the best price so my personal
opinion my ranking for an everyday user
would be ipad mini ipad pro and then the
iPad air the reason that iPad pro
supersedes the iPad air for an everyday
user is because if you are making the
decision between an iPad
and a pro you need this for a laptop
style device the iPad pro has those
capabilities has those extra
functionalities and has the better
note-taking capabilities with the
second-generation pencil I don't think
it warrants the price difference there's
no way I would spend that much if I had
to choose but it is the better device
out of those two that's all I have for
you guys today thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did smash nothing to subscribe
button 20:20 style and because we're
still all locked up in quarantine I will
see you on Wednesday